Con este tipo de activismo,
y la inversión en la comunidad que caracteriza a la peluquería negra,
por supuesto, la peluquería es un lugar perfecto
para hablar de presión arterial alta y otros problemas de salud en la comunidad.
En primer lugar, la peluquería no es un entorno médico,
y por tanto no tiene todo ese bagaje psicológico negativo
asociado a eso.
Cuando estás en una barbería,
uno está en su propio territorio, y está entre amigos
con quien compartir su historia,
su lucha y sus riesgos para la salud.
En segundo lugar, como la peluquería es un lugar de conexión,
lealtad y confianza,
es un lugar donde uno está más abierto a conversar sobre salud
y sobre todo sobre presión arterial alta.
Después de todo, las conversaciones sobre presión arterial alta
tienen todos los elementos de una buena charla:
estrés y presión arterial alta,
alimentación y presión arterial alta,
relaciones y presión arterial alta,
y sí, lo que se siente siendo un hombre negro en EE.UU.
y la presión arterial alta.
Pero se puede hacer más que tan solo hablar de la presión arterial alta
en la peluquería.
Uno puede tomar medidas concretas.
Aquí tenemos la oportunidad de asociarnos con el Denny Moe del mundo
y dar autonomía a las comunidades para hacer frente a las desigualdades en salud
que afectan de manera particular.
Cuando la comunidad de la exploración de la presión arterial alta
de las clínicas y hospitales a las comunidades en la década del 60 y 70,
los médicos negros como el Dr. Eli Saunders en Baltimore
y el Dr. Keith Ferdinand en Nueva Orleans
estaban en la vanguardia en la promoción de la salud llevando centros comunitarios
a los barrios negros urbanos.
Estos pioneros abrieron el camino a mi trayectoria profesional
con las barberías y la salud,
que comenzó en Chicago en la facultad de medicina.
En el 1er proyecto de investigación en el que trabajé siendo estudiante de medicina
ayudaba a diseñar intervenciones para el cuidado de la salud
que atrajeran a los hombres negros.
Hemos dirigido unos 12 grupos
con una amplia muestra representativa de hombres negros,
y aprendimos que para ellos
estar sano era ser percibido como saludable.
Como si sentirse saludable,
y esa buena sensación fuesen mano a mano con un buen aspecto.
Este trabajo condujo el desarrollo del Proyecto Hermandad,
una clínica de la comunidad fundada por el Dr. Eric Whitaker
que daba asistencia sanitaria personalizada a hombres negros.
Parte de esta atención personalizada
implicaba tener un peluquero en las instalaciones
para recompensar a los hombres que vinieran a la asistencia sanitaria
con un corte de pelo gratis.
Hacer que los hombres supieran que nosotros también valoramos el aspecto,
así como también cómo se sentían,
y que lo que era importante para ellos también lo era para nosotros.
Sin embargo, mientras que solo hay un Proyecto Hermandad,
hay miles de peluquerías para hombres negros
donde la intersección de la salud y cortes de pelo puede ser cultivada.
La siguiente parada de mi viaje era de Dallas, Texas,
donde aprendimos que los barberos no solo estaban dispuestos
sino que eran totalmente capaces de arremangarse y participar
en la prestación de servicios de salud para mejorar la salud de sus clientes
y su comunidad.
Nos asociamos con un increíble grupo de peluqueros negros
y se les enseñó a medir la presión arterial
y a aconsejar a sus clientes
y remitirlos a los médicos
para ayudar a controlar la presión arterial alta.
Los barberos no solo estaban dispuestos a hacerlo
sino que eran muy buenos haciéndolo.
Durante un período de tres años,
los barberos tomaron miles de presiones arteriales
dando como resultado que cientos de hombres negros fueron a los médicos
para la atención médica por su presión arterial alta.
Estas asociaciones barbero-médico
han dado lugar a un aumento del 20 % en el número de hombres
capaces de alcanzar los niveles objetivo de presión arterial
y una caída de tres puntos, en promedio,
en la presión sanguínea de cada participante.
Si extrapoláramos la caída de tres puntos
a cada hombre negro solo con presión arterial alta en EE.UU.
evitaríamos 800 ataques cardíacos, 500 accidentes cerebrovasculares
y 900 muertes por presión arterial alta
en solo un año.
Y nuestra experiencia con las peluquerías no ha sido diferente
en la ciudad de Nueva York, a donde recientemente mi viaje me ha llevado.
Con un equipo increíble de diversos asistentes en la investigación,
los trabajadores de salud comunitarios y voluntarios,
hemos podido asociarnos con más de 200 peluquerías
y otros lugares de confianza para la comunidad
para llegar a más de 7000 hombres mayores negros.
Y hemos ofrecido evaluaciones de presión arterial alta y asesoramiento
a todos y cada uno de ellos.
Gracias a Denny Moe
y a la miríada de otros barberos y líderes de la comunidad
que compartieron la visión de oportunidades y el empoderamiento
para hacer una diferencia en sus comunidades,
no solo hemos logrado reducir la presión arterial
en nuestros participantes,
sino también hemos mejorado otros indicadores de salud.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que ven?
¿Cuál es su barbería?
¿Dónde está ese lugar para Ud.
donde las personas afectadas por un problema único
pueden obtener una solución única?
Cuando encuentren ese lugar, tengan en cuenta esa oportunidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)